as projective measurements. By the way, this degeneracy only happens in the simplified description
of quantum information.
When we describe quantum
states using density matrices, as we will do in the
third unit of the series, we will have a unique
matrix representation
for every quantum state. The issue of global phases
simply doesn't arise in the general description
of quantum information.
It's one more appealing aspect
of the general description of quantum information,
which I keep alluding to, but regardless, global
phases won't bother us
because we can just exercise
our freedom to ignore them.
Here's a very quick
example just to make sure the notion of a global phase is clear.
If we have a minus state, and negative one times a minus state, then these two states
differ by a global phase, and in particular we have
alpha equals negative one.
On the other hand, if we have a plus state and a minus state, then we don't have two states
that differ by a global phase.
These are orthogonal vectors, so they're linearly independent.
To say that two quantum state vectors differ by a global phase
is equivalent to saying that the vectors are linearly dependent,
so certainly these vectors
don't differ by a global phase.
It's true that the only difference is that this plus sign
turns into this minus sign, but that's what we call a
relative phase difference.
That's different from a global phase because we're not
multiplying the entire vector by a complex number.
And this is consistent with the fact that we can tell the difference
between these states, in particular, if we
apply a Hadamard operation
and then measure, we'll see a zero if the
state was a plus state and a one if the state was a minus state.
The next limitation of quantum information that we'll see in this lesson
is the no-cloning theorem.
Here's one statement of
the no-cloning theorem and this particular
statement of the theorem is pretty concrete and specific,
which will make it easier to talk about. There are other more general ways to formulate the no-cloning theorem,
but we'll focus on this one for now.
We assume that we have two systems X and Y which have the same classical state set.
which consists of the
integer from zero to D-1 where D is at least two.
It's not really important what names the classical states have, but by choosing these names it'll help to keep things simple.
What's most important
here is that there are at least two different classical
states, so in other words, we're not worrying about the
trivial and uninteresting case
where we only have one classical state.
What the theorem says is that there's no unitary operation U that we can apply to X, Y so that if we initialize
Y to the zero state,
we effectively copy or clone
arbitrary quantum states of X.
If we take a look at this
expression right here in isolation, what it says is that for all choices of a quantum state vector Psi of X,
applying U to Psi tensored
with the zero state, gives us Psi tensor Psi, or in other words two
independent copies of Psi,
so that's what it would mean if we could clone quantum
states and what the theorem says is that this is not possible.
You can think about this
in terms of circuits and what the theorem says is
that you'll never be able to come up with a gate or a circuit
that works as you see here.
Where one copy of the state Psi comes in along with a collection
of initialized Qubits and two copies of Psi are produced.
You can do this for certain
choices of the state Psi, but you can never come up with
a circuit that works this way for every quantum state Psi,
and that's what the theorem says.
It's quite easy to prove
this theorem, in fact, it essentially boils down to the fact that the transformation we're
looking for isn't linear,
but unitary operations are
linear, so it just can't work.
Here's an argument in a bit more detail.
Suppose that we have a unitary operation U that clones the standard basis
states, Ket 0 and Ket one.
We know that the classical
states zero and one must belong to our classical state set because D is at least two.
But this means by linearity
that if X is in a plus state, which we can write like this,
then the result is this linear combination of these two states right here.
However, that's not the right behavior. The requirement on U is that
U cloned is a plus state,
which means that we have to
have this equation right here being satisfied.
These two states aren't the
same and so it doesn't work and that's all there is to it.
Just a few additional remarks
about the no-cloning theorem.
First, this statement of the
no-cloning theorem is absolute in some sense.
It simply says that a unitary operation U that works exactly like
this doesn't exist.
So you might ask whether
or not there exists unitary operation U that
does this approximately with respect to some way of describing